toute la famille bienvenue nous sommes
dimanche soir il est 21h tout pile et on
se retrouve sur instagram pour un live
spécial drafté à plaindre un truc à dire
lors évidemment pour en parler et comme
d'habitude on a invité les copains
d'envergure c'est romain qui met à me
rejoindre dans quelques minutes pour
justement en discuter de tout ça mais en
attendant je vous souhaite la bienvenue
les amis venait tranquillement installé
vous on va pouvoir parler de draft je
sais que ça tient à coeur de beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de monde sachant que
dès demain on se retrouve sur youtube
avec le retour des vidéos et demain il y
aura ce thème
il y aura évidemment erwan il y aura il
colle à batum on se posera la question
de ce que vaudra ce titre on pourra
parler de plein de choses des équipes
peut-être en forme on n'a pas trop
d'infos encore aujourd'hui mais là vu
les relents de auckland plein de choses
on a plein d'infos on pouvait dérouler
aussi le programme des matches de
préparation bref ce sera très
intéressant ça se passe dès demain dans
la journée sur youtube avec nicolas
batum qui est en france et qui dans la
de la chance il va bien sur le plateau
pour discuter avec nous fait leurs
vidéos youtube ce sera pour bientôt on
aura le temps de parler de noël temps de
parler draft un peu plus tard puisque
c'est mi octobre donc tranquillement je
regarde arthur demain zoom sur quelle
franchise et non mon ami demain comme je
viens de le dire nous parlons de la
reprise nba vous savez c'est le 30
juillet et donc il ya plein de surprises
plein de programmes qui vont arriver et
on pourra parler de tout ça alors
j'invite romain déchets envergure et on
voit comment le petit programme du jour
en attendant notre ami roma roma roman
est souvent tombé
est-ce que tu m'entends au moins vingt
romain roman un roman est ce que tu es
là tu as plus qu'à accepter connexion
let's go très gros mais ça va écoute ça
va ça moi ça me rassure sur mes
capacités à me connecter sur un compte
instagram je suis pas du tout pas du
tout habitués comme ça on est encore sur
la couleur voilà les dossiers là en tant
que supporters des rucks et et c'est que
moi c'est plus c'est plutôt à il ya
place à commencer plus tôt lituanien bon
monsieur
voilà c'était pourquoi en at elle dit
le ps a surtout appelé plein de trucs tu
l'avais vu avant de présenter pour ceux
qui ne te connaissent pas tu pourra nous
dire ce que tu fais dans la vie j'ai
envie de te dire une identité
mais avant ça je voulais juste faire le
programme du jour on va parler de la
djibi que puisqu'on sait que pas mal de
montereau spect pour 2021 vont passer
par la case g-league plutôt que la
caisse ait jihed qui vont prendre de
l'argent à quoi s'attendre et ainsi de
suite il ya pas mal de questions on va
parler aussi de la draft d'une 21 2020
2020 pardon sur le programme le mois
d'octobre
comment vont se passer les workouts il
ya pas mal de choses et pas mal de
questions a parlé des français aussi
puisque on sait que cinq françaises sur
mon taf c'est le record historique pour
nos petits frenchies qui ont été choisis
à la draft
on verra si cette année on peut en avoir
cinq ou plus j'espère que tu as préparé
des petites réponses mon avis ceux qui
ne connaissent pas c'est toujours
difficile de parler de cela
moi ça fait ça fait quelques éléments
sur une croisière et instagram donc déjà
avec avec vous et de manière globale tu
utilise très peu le trait postmedia là
moi ça fait quelques années donc je
tourne avec mes petits camarades du
d'envergure du podcast mois titre perso
je suis je suis lent basket projette
assistant cette année à antibes en pro b
et je j'ai bougé à gecina strasbourg la
sig pour la pour la saison prochaine
donc j'arrive j'arrive en egypte l'élite
j'espère pouvoir continuer mes activités
mes activités de consultant comme
podcast en parallèle puis voilà il n'y a
pas pas grand chose de plus à dire je
pense oui c'est de parler de basket dix
ans mais évidemment là vous avez envie
d'acier de trois bombes ne te prive pas
c'est le moment c'est pas le genre de la
maison
c'est un très beau projet une
reconstruction à gm étrangers un coach
étranger qui connaît bien sûr cette
france là donc il ya de quoi faire mon
camarade franck hulk est à limoges
arrive aussi la lui comme comme adjoint
également donc on travaille on travaille
dans l'ombre pour construire et qui est
profitable construire l'équipe très
intéressant et très motivé une belle
opportunité nous sera l'occasion pour
les types évite une autre fois mais
aujourd'hui on attendra les des
prospects des futures stars
billet j'ai envie de te dire hélas le
premier nom que je vais citer
aujourd'hui
pourtant c'est que pour la draft 2021
c'est jonathan cooling à un congolais
qui cette semaine a décidé de s'équiper
complètement la case n 6 est pourrait
directement angeli on sait qu'à geely
est en train un peu de révolutionnaire
bleus l'entre-deux avant la nba hier en
proposant une équipe une sélective votre
dossier par brent quelques infos là
dessus ouais c'est le sépare yachou il y
avait plusieurs candidats sur le poste
de coach avait notamment notamment
fidèles et brian shaw principalement
comme comme nom qui ressortait je sais
que l'équipe
l'équipe sera basée à los angeles il
parlait il n'y a pas si longtemps que ça
peut-être de localiser au moins toute la
partie centre d'entraînement sur
l'assuré mamba academy donc un projet un
petit peu un peu composite on parlait de
saint-aulaye l'impôt leur centre fédéral
a eu on va dire quelque chose mais
quelque chose de novateur et puis qui
bon je vois un peu partagé gg de la
division entraîneur et l'autre vision
mais qui peut être quelque chose
d'intéressant et de curieux avoir enfin
curieux de voir comment ça évolue et
ouais tu parlais du centre fédéral alors
évidemment le parallèle est vrai bien
parallèles c'est un raccourci
évidemment le son de fédérale est bien
le but c'est de créer des pros pas de
créer de les former et leur laisser le
temps aussi de se former là pour le coup
les joueurs seront payés jonathan
jonathan 2000 gaz devrait payer 5
dollars la saison donc c'est aussi pour
ça qu'il va qu'il va en jig mais on
promet aussi on va lui laisser le temps
de se développer et que lui se prépare
pour être papa numéro 1 la prochaine
draft
donc quand même c'est un tour tant que
tu vois la différence entre il est payé
en même temps il ya une progression
attendue
sait on est dans une source interne et
le débat est ce que les escales est ce
que les joueurs doivent être payés à la
fac on se pose la question le wpt london
est ce que c'est bien ce que c'est pas
bien le fait que les gens ils skient
parfois la fac ils veulent directement
les mêmes billets je pense qu'il ya un
paramètre qu'on n'arrive pas appréhendé
parce que c'est tellement loin
c'est l'aspect financier et le fait qu'
on peut mettre sa famille à l'abri très
rapidement on parle quand même de gens
pour la plupart qui sortent 2000
défavorisés est encore parfois c'est un
euphémisme c'est parfois plus que ça
donc il est légitime que les gens
cherchent le plus tôt possible à à
trouver la solution qui permettra
justement peut-être de bad monnayer ses
talents
l'idée de la nba dans le cas la
sélective je la trouve intéressante
parce que ça va permettre à ces jeunes
joueurs des dans un cadre de pannes ont
pu partir dans tous les sens pas
forcément arriver en une bille est trop
tôt parce que il y en a qui se sont
brûlé les ailes aussi on sait par le
passé et puis après reste à voir si ça
tiendra le coup mais il parle également
d'avoir une foule scholarship ans pour
aller à la fac à côté et c'était avec ce
cas on ça en pratique quand on
s'entraîne deux fois par jour de
probables ça me paraît plus un argument
commercial qu'autre chose mais bon on
verra ouvert à usage un joueur fait
confiance je pense que quand les leviers
seront sur des projets en général c'est
c'est rarement fermons les yeux rare -
l'aveuglent donc c'est intéressant après
le fait de concentrer beaucoup de talent
on est en en tête tout à l'heure je suis
à une équipe ça peut-être lever des
questions mais en tout cas je trouve
l'idée intéressante et est peut-être
plus effectivement que de ce fait
remarquer à 18 ans et saufs
sauf si on est droit - joueur
incontournable on sait quand on se fait
le racheter à 18 ans il ya une pression
énorme quand on arrive un billet tout de
suite là ça permet de redescendre un
petit peu et justement de 37 ans la
toile a point de vue coach et d'un point
de vue global
évidemment chaque cas est très
particulier mais on peut comparer donc
des choix qui vont à la fac qui vont
jouer des mecs qui tue même âge non
payés là des professionnels donc l'été
jeunes joueurs que je comptais
professionnel on appuie aussi imaginer
que ces joueurs là haye en europe on a
déjà vu par le passé je pense à bonn
jennings par exemple qui avait fait une
année en italie donc c'est aussi un
moyen libérer du cash et de frotter aux
meilleurs joueurs
est ce que toi en tant que coach c'était
un gars a conseillé qui à 18 ans est ce
qu'il ya une piste que tu préfèrerais
voilà la meilleure piste s'est trouvé
l'endroit le plus approprié pour
travailler parce que les raccourcis
c'est bien mais le cas de génie mais il
est intéressant mais ça réveillait
disons aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui un jeu je peux pas tout dire
les choses que je peux pas j'ai des
informations de chose d'autre qui dira
mais concernant concernant qu'une gare
je sais qu'un intermédiaire à 6 le cas
dans un club de pro b d'accord
voilà et le souci c'est moi la question
que je me suis posée quand j'ai entendu
parler c'est est-ce qu'aujourd'hui le
basket pratiqué en pro b pour un jeune
joueur comme ça qui arrive de l'étranger
est facile aujourd'hui on a on a deux
jeunes joueurs très intéressants que ce
soit des gars 1 et kamagaté dans le
projet de paris avec ses pattes qui
arrive à choper les minutes mais c'est
des gamins qui culturellement grandi
dans le basket français
je vais pas dur de lui que la probable
inaccessible pendant trois semaines et
demie et c'est pas du tout le propos
mais ça ça fait un changement de culture
alors que nous ces jours là restent dans
leur culture tente et l'europe c'est
difficile l'australie comme c'était le
cas pour pour rendez-vous dans ball
l'australie c'est encore autre chose
parce que tu restes dans un contexte
anglophone dont tu sors pas totalement
ta zone de confort et l'australie c'est
quand même pas de championnat depuis
défensif du monde non plus donc quelque
part tu peux aussi tenues très l'europe
ça le côté barbelés fait que ça peut ça
peut poser problème
non pas que le joueur n'aurait pas le
talent mais c'est plus sûr sur la
stabilité sur la culture sur plein de
choses moi j'ai j'ai vu des roues tuait
sortir de très bons programmes
universitaires arrive en france j'en ai
bien à quelques années le mec qui savait
pas se faire à bouffer c'est ce magicien
rade c'est terrible mais c'est ça donc
aujourd'hui et c'est un gamin de 18 ans
si tu le sort de son pays d'une autre
culture publié les congolais donc c'est
encore c'est encore un cadet pourquoi
ils font toutefois plusieurs les
francophones ça peut aider mais quelque
part tu sais c'est une vraie mise en
difficulté moi j'ai fait une saison à
l'étranger
c'était pas très loin c'est enfin le
fait de se délocaliser comme ça c'est un
pic des choses alors l'âge que j'avais
c'était ce n'était pas forcément évident
tous les jours pour un gamin de 18 ans
avec la pression qu'il peut y avoir
voilà moi je moi je pour revenir à la
question des par la priorité c est ce qu
on peut travailler si le contexte est
bon pour travailler on n'est pas bon
pour moi s'il n'y a pas de souci de ce
côté là il ya un truc qui est
intéressant aussi au delà même du fait
de s'adapter admettons que le jeune
cerbère à ce nouvel environnement il ya
un truc qui est clair c'est que pour
aller à la draft
il faut pour cela des choses et la 6è
mine de rien te permet pas ce que tu es
forcément au dessus quand tu es un gros
prospects te permet de te montrer de
faire des stats de rater aussi des
choses de prendre des responsabilités et
on peut imaginer alors s'emparer de la
g-league mai
si je prends l'exemple de l'europe il
faut quand même que les joueurs aient 18
ans soient assez forts pour des
responsabilités là où il ya beaucoup de
pression donc les attentes et la
dilution du jeu aussi complètement après
après là il sied à un autre paramètre
qui rentrent en ligne de compte c'est
que quand tu que tu vas sur les
chevreuils sur les grosses vagues sur
les vraiment sur lui sur les femmes qui
servent d'abord sur le prospect 5
étoiles je sois kent it is you qui
réussiront pas toutes les citer tu as un
tel réseau de gens qu'aujourd'hui le
fait que ces joueurs là soit dans ces
écoles là pour avoir des intel pour
savoir le joueur comme il est avec cette
carax et car il ya tellement lien entre
les coaches les scouts etc
les choses se font vite l'exposition les
intéressante sur les grosses vagues pour
ça en europe les équipes ont les équipes
et 2 millions d'e on des réseaux de deux
consultants également mais l'exposition
évidemment citer à duke c'est aussi bien
à dieu quelques quand l'autre dans
d'autres temps d'autres contextes à
l'étranger et surtout tu vas toujours
être sûr du haut niveau ou presque
donc il ya moins le côté un peu
aléatoire la la la g-league il y aura
peut-être pas la même intensité où la
même pression tu vas pas jouer un final
four universitaire tu vas pas joué de
mars madness sauf que en termes de vie
de construction d'expérience ya des
choses que tu auras pas forcément mais
tu vas te frotter à des joueurs
expérimentés
tu vas dans un contexte sera plus
favorable au développement individuel je
dirai pas ce qu'en dit li que c'est pas
forcément sur le sur l'aspect collectif
qu'on va faire qu'on va trop se
développer même si certaines équipes
jouent canin basket intéressant je
regarde beaucoup en ce moment et je peux
je peux en parler un petit peu mais non
le contexte pour moi c'est c'est une
espèce d'entre eux sol on va dire qui
peut permettre à un jeune joueur de
concilier un petit peu ce qui va
chercher professionnellement dans le
développement et ce qui va pouvoir lui
trouver pour subsister à ses besoins et
éventuellement aider aider sur
l'entourage et cetera et cetera sans
pour autant partir dans un réseau
d'agents pas forcément toujours claire
de sponsors entre unis mais de l'ex star
ac ça peut permettre je pense de
débroussailler beaucoup de choses et
d'avoir un contexte relativement saint
benoît jeu notre ambitieux attentes
munga donc il va rejoindre public dans
la sélective
tu parlais tout à l'heure
du profit de cette équipe on se rappelle
coachée par brain show autour des lakers
du magic ancien coach nba aussi donc
c'est un projet un peu intéressant pour
un coach qui était un peu en galère
entre guillemets ces dernières saisons
il va rejoindre dans le budget john
green day à todd d'etion knicks et kaïs
auto pour les plus connus des futurs
prospects
comment est-ce que tu justement ce cette
formation des équipes de jeunes
prospects qui vont sauter on disait tout
à l'heure à des adultes avec toujours la
dalle c'est sûr après un plus en plus
donc c'est quand même globalement des
joueurs à leur niveau référencer des
joueurs incontournables sur leur sur la
génération future classe d'âge voilà la
seule question n'en a parlé que les
camarades envergure la seule question
qui est juste un peu un consensus
le truc qui ressort c'est ça fait
beaucoup de talent il ya qu un ballon et
accents exploite sur le terrain donc
inévitablement c'est ça peut poser
question
surtout qu'à l'heure actuelle la
situation c'est le café qu'on n'a pas
forcément de pair c'est qu'ils n'ont
plus sûres quand ça va reprendre déjà si
ça va reprendre
on espère quand ça va reprendre comment
donc on n'a pas de on n'a pas d'horizon
réellement distincts de ce côté-là et s
qui aura assez de matches la question
aussi et puis après le partage des
minutes sont encore assez encore un lot
de soucis mais bon je pense qu'il vaut
mieux avoir plus de talent
éventuellement et puis quitte à avoir ou
deux joueurs expérimentés un moment
autour mais c'est ça peut donner quelque
chose de très intéressant et je pense
que les il faut modérer les attentes
dans ce sens où on parle de joueurs il
faut encore une fois faut être patient
et de plus en plus c'est que les jeunes
joueront d'aller trop vite c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui le moindre gamins que la
15 16 ans on va trouver des comparaisons
avec un tel début je suis catastrophée
par je ne sais pas faire des
comparaisons de voir un joueur parce que
les résultats sont souvent sont souvent
dramatiques dans ce que je propose donc
arrêter de le faire mais je pense qu'il
faut se donner du temps où on veut aller
trop vite
le système global fait qu'on veut aller
vite aussi parce qu'il ya des enjeux
encore une fois qu'ils sont qu'au delà
du sportif
mais j'espère j'espère encore une fois
que les choses se feront bien parce
qu'en plus âgés la liste sous les yeux
il ya pas mal de joueurs qui vont être
sur les mêmes postes donc en concurrence
directe quelque chose que tu au niveau
universitaire aussi mais au niveau
universitaire quoi tuer cinq étoiles
comme ça
peut jouer tout de suite il ya des
coachs qui vont te faire jouer mais très
souvent on sait comment ça se passe un
joueur universitaire il va toujours
mériter son temps de jeu attendre un
petit peu donc si un joueur plus âgé
devant plus talentueux il va attendre un
petit peu c'est de moins en moins vrai
que le wild bunch jeudi avec avec
vraiment les recrutera est armé mais la
voilà là le problème c'est la densité
puis beaucoup de joueurs sur les postes
2 3 voir ce que ça de voir ce que ça
peut donner
c'est ce que est ce que là comme ça avec
tous les éléments qu'on a est ce que tu
penses que ça peut être derrière une
vraie alternative à la si cette équipe
une alternative je sais pas parce que on
a beau s'entraîner tout ce qu'on veut on
a beau on a beau jouer autant de matches
qu'on veut je pense que rien ne remplace
les matches 11 mai des vrais matchs en
jeu c'est à dire que côté dans le
contexte universitaire quand tu joues tu
es match de conférence ils ont un enjeu
tu représentes ton école tu deviennes et
tapas à la march madness c'est quelque
chose qui est qui est important dans la
culture dans la culture du sport us
quant à la march madness tu sais
quelques parts potentiellement chaque
match peut être le dernier essai des
choses qui je vais faire ils enfoncer
les portes ouvertes j'aime bien les gars
j'aime bien les lieux communs comme ça
mais c'est sa ford les hommes et sa
forge des joueurs aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui tu prends le cas d'un joueur
comme si elle est dotée au mal et on
n'en parlait tout à l'heure où il ya 2
il ya deux ans dont titre c'est les
joueurs qui arrivent aux états unis en
ayant connu le haut niveau européen ou
au moins d'eau moins leur coeur pour
pour qu'ils analysent mais avec des
matches anges et des responsabilités
ce qui fait que âge équivalent ils sont
plus expérimentés que les maîtres sont
en phase 2 c'est la raison pour laquelle
un joueur comme comme sékou doumbouya
sur les workouts il est capable et
efficace face à des mails qui jouait sur
des grosses vagues pourquoi parce qu'il
sait taper de l'eurocup
quand il a quoi dessus à vivre ça sisi
workout avait été organisée correctement
cette année avec la situation sanitaire
on sait qu'à pour l'instant il a rien de
faire réellement un joueur comme s'ils
allaient ils auraient aurait eu sa carte
à jouer face à des joueurs de son âge et
ça peut jouer sur la côte passe encore
une fois avec tout le respect que je
peux avoir pour le dit
jouer de l'euroligue aux jouets de leurs
roquettes oui évidemment
voilà c'est pas les mêmes enjeux c'est
pas les mêmes salles c'est pas les mêmes
joueurs en face à la pression du
quotidien tu t'entraînes différemment
même si encore une fois je suis pas en
train de dire que le dis que c'est pas
intéressant ça reste un champion
laquelle il ya des bons joueurs et il ya
des bons coachs également une sorte de
gel guérissent un hasard mais nouveau
coach de zalgiris était le coach de
l'équipe de j league de salt lake city
donc quelque part je pense que si une
équipe d'euroligue est capable d'aller
chercher un coach comme ça il ya quand
même quelque chose donc penser c'est ça
reste je pense que dans la logistique et
dans l'organisation c'est très bien
quels leviers face ça parce que ça
permet de cadrer un peu les choses et ça
permet peut-être d'éviter aussi que les
prospects portes partout et dans des
situations où il était difficile de
suivre tout le monde et surtout de
savoir ce qu'ils font las les choses
elles sont ou seront elles seront elles
seront elles seront ils seront elles
seront cadrer correctement sauce ennemis
y est en tout cas ce sera une année
peut-être tronquée évidemment on espère
on espère que ça va prendre à peu près
normalement
mais cette équipe là elle sera très
intéressante à suivre
soit ce sera l'occasion de découvrir
tous ces jeunes joueurs dans le voile à
277 gillick avec avec un ange et quand
ils disaient qu'ils étaient un peu un
peu flou mais il n'empêche c'est une
vraie invention et toi je crois être
pied de nez de d'alternative
c'est en tout cas une tentative de nba
de créer quelque chose intéressante à
suivre face au conservatisme tu sais qui
qui pour moi bloque tout entier sait
quelque chose et puis je repense il me
semble que c'est jacques monclar lâché 2
mg bid qui naissaient n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça ce qui se passe en ce
moment en terme de situation sanitaire
ou à ce que tant qu ennemi c'est une
espèce de laboratoire fois qu'il disait
quelque chose comme ça où on va tenter
des choses et voir ce qu'il peut se
passer et peut-être que des trucs
intéressants vont en sortir la limite
c'est tant mieux parce que le but c'est
quand même que le sport évolue les
choses sont pas figées c'est pas mal et
à des gamins des volants bonne situation
de notre condition qu'on va c'est
parfait absolute a vu huit mois est vite
fait un coming à jouer tu as vu de 3
j'ai vu j'ai vu alors les des situations
web et cesser plus des situations de
highlight soucoupe et autres parce que
pour choper des madiot lycée c'est pas
forcément toujours toujours évident
évident surtout cette année sinon
général quand tu arrives sur les sur les
matchs de fin de saison sur les tournois
de fin de saison
paris toujours avoir avoir quelques
trucs là c'était c'était un peu tronqué
un peu tronquée bon il a l'air d'avoir
deux trois qualités notre ami quand même
là il a quelques qualités
bon déjà le fait qu'il ait réussi à
reclasser d'une année la diplômée de
high school c'est je pensais plutôt bon
fils parce que le gamin de maîtriser son
projet un petit peu aussi
il ya eu une époque art and flag sur ses
genoux ou c'était un petit peu sa
couille est un petit peu mais
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai phénomène
physique espèce de poste 3 ça peut
devenir l'extraterrestre clairement de
match 0-3 qualités athlétiques belle
mécanique de shoot des votes la lettre
que voilà il est capable d'être peu plus
tôt créatif pas le moment c'est des
trucs qu'on espère en tout cas le voir
bosser l'année prochaine et il arrivera
à développer dans le monde professionnel
on sait que c'est toujours très
difficile mais c'est quelqu'un sur qui
il faudra compter complètement puis sas
sas moi ça met en valeur bon il a il a
été développée ces derniers offrent ces
dernières années pardon aux états unis
mais c'est comme tuer dit tout à l'heure
mais né au congo je veux dire quelque
part fo on n'imagine pas le potentiel
qui en afrique quoi il ya des académies
qui sont dans différents pays
il ya même des joueurs opèrent de plus
en plus tous s'investissent et c'est
très bien parce que voilà je disais tout
à l'heure il ya le contexte sportif mais
tout ce qui va autour ça te permettent à
des gamins de sortir d'avancé et puis
deux à leur tour de rendre et de mettre
des gens à l'abri et que c'était
excitant le dire tant mieux c'est
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire et
c'est tant mieux c'est pour ça qu'un
truc indique aussi la lie de nba qui
maillent confrères de travaux projet
passionnant
en afrique ce sera un titre très
intéressant à suivre
on est évidemment dans parlera dans les
émissions parce que le potentiel tu
disais est tout à fait énorme rachète
sur un autre sujet on va parler de la
draft 2020 avec tout ce qui se passe ces
derniers temps alors qu'est ce qu'on en
sait est ce que tu as des dates à
nourrir pour 2020 alors logiquement
l'adorable 2020
le 17 dollar le 3 août c'était la
deadline pour les joueurs initiés pour
savoir si oui ou non il reste candidat
où ils peuvent ils peuvent retourner à
l'école 17 août deadline le dépôt des
candidatures 3 octobre
ils peuvent elles peuvent se retirer les
joueurs internationaux avec cet art etc
et logiquement la draft est calée au 16
octobre logiquement a à l'heure actuelle
je crois je peux me tromper mais je
crois que les scouts ne se déplace pas
cirque y compris sur les sites hull et
les choses qui ont repris les compagnies
l'espèce de consensus et d'équité quand
les gens regardent mais je crois que les
gens ne se déplacent pas pour aller voir
les joueurs s'entraîner parce que on les
choses qu'on ne peut cadrer ce qui est
logique parce que ne peut pas être
avantagé d'un côté et ainsi de suite
donc voilà les 6es les matches ou des
choses comme ça oui après sur tout ce
qui est en train de m'en et compagnies
non il ya des interviews qui se font
essentiellement essentiellement en ligne
je sais qu'il ya des joueurs qui qui
continue à suivre le procès interview
mais bon normalement la draft rapport le
16 octobre
ce serait très étonnant en tout cas ne
pas avoir de graves conflits ne pas
avoir de work out c'est possible qu'il
n'est pas du tout donc ce serait une
draft
enfin c'est impossible d'imaginer le
processus aux tensions c'est aussi pour
ça que c'est la course à l'information
et que le moindre coach perso s'il peut
se faire accrocher par un scout au
téléphone j'en connais quelques-uns qui
doit voir le téléphone qui sonne
beaucoup et à la limite c'est le jeu
mais voilà c'est vrai que une draft sans
qu'on gagne sans rien sans les choses
très particulière mais c'est aussi ce
qui fait que ceux projetés à l'heure
actuelle sur une future big board sur
une box ou même sur sur la valeur d'un
joueur sans les choses très compliquées
parce que il suffit d'une interview
quelque chose comme ça tant qu'on n'a
pas vu les gens rendu réel ou si tel ou
tel joueur
le jour où gm ou le scout est venu le
voir s'il n'est pas un peu penser à
travers le chant de plein de choses
peuvent changer alors je dis pas que ça
va se jouer à pas de 20 à 30 mais tu
peux avoir des répercussions
parmi les répercussions
de cet art un peu décalé c'est qu'il ya
des joueurs des bons joueurs qui étaient
attendus à la draft qui décide de
revenir une 6è pour conforter leur place
par exemple continuer à progresser
oui ça peut être une seule peut être une
solution si ta ta ta des joueurs qui
peuvent choisir ses taux de change là
parce qu'en plus de toute façon faute de
garanties suffisantes comme certains
pouvant récupérer par des franchises
tu peux pas non plus prendre le risque
de se retrouver le bec dans l'eau c'est
encore deux voire trois ans
d'éligibilité faire une deuxième à la
fois que c'est quelque chose dont plus
est de toute façon la date du 3 août
elle est pour moi très complexe à gérer
sur le sur le timing pour les joueurs
mais c'est peut-être aussi ce qu'ils
vont pousser certains peut-être affaire
tapie à dire j'y vais d'autres
finalement à venir un puncheur décision
attentes et attentionné aller plus
d'avoir entré dans les affaires de poker
menteur
maintenant il va qui va pas ne pas avoir
de meilleurs moyens j'ai envie de te
dire de juger certains joueurs
américains qui souffre ou internationaux
qui sont ici et là on a absolument aucun
les talons cette saison pour pouvoir
casser ses jours ce que tu puisses tu as
ta place à permet des mecs doivent
travailler et le joueur la poste de se
poster en deux jours ils surent carcelle
edwards s'est elle a racheté par boston
l'an dernier il explose complètement une
portion de l'équipe quand on arrive sur
la march madness
voilà c'est mais comme ça peut marquer
les esprits comme certains aussi chute
mais ça ça peut aussi ça peut aussi
servir de révélateur d'accord très bien
y aller qu'il veut qu'on parle de xavier
thilleman ouais la ferrade au michigan
absolument qui a décidé de revenir lui
pour son jeu les passagers pas je n'ai
pas forcément assez suivie mais lui l'a
décidé justement de revenir pour pour
son année pour son année senior et sa
seconde et parmi ces mecs là qui
reviennent tout ce bordel à quelques
bides fait que ces mecs-là revient à la
fac c'est exactement ce qu'on disait
alors qu'aujourd'hui tu vas te couper
aujourd'hui je sais pas si tu as vu je
crois que c'est aujourd'hui hier
aujourd'hui la initié a commencé à
mettre de gros pointillés sur ce qu'il
appelle les sports d'automne c'est à
dire que je sais plus à quoi ça
correspond exactement inclure calendrier
de deux saisons mais voilà c'est tout ce
qui est foutue et ses compagnies sur la
reprise commence à rire commence à
prendre des pincettes puisque la
situation sanitaire est telle chez eux
que que c'est difficile donc
j'espère qu'on aura pas au basket après
derrière mais bon face à presser c'est
du sport secondaire ab-so-lu-ment c'est
ce qu'on aime ballon un peu des français
wade pas mal de français qui sont
attendus et kids and isles
ces dégâts on a envie de voir qu'on
espère voir d'abord au premier tour pour
kilian pourquoi pas on part le top 5 top
10 je sais que son envergure bleus
passaient très où vous avez beaucoup
d'espoir son potentiel père fait partie
des 5 de ceux qui sont emballés par son
potentiel
je les ai vus jouer pas la saison qui
vient de s'achever la saison d'avant
j'ai dû le voir jouer 12 13 fois j'ai vu
son évolution d'un dernier j'ai vu je
les ai vus jouer sur coty ont dû jouer à
monaco dernier je suis passé je suis pas
ce match c'est un journée d'entraînement
et j'ai vu l'évolution du bonhomme je
trouve que son son choix d'aller en
allemagne était surpris pas mal de monde
mais le championnat normalement être
très bonne qualité
il ad je trouve qu'il ya développé un
lien très intéressant avec son avec son
coach qui était juste une légende
d'euroligue
parce qu'elles étaient l'écho mx et écho
à malraux monsieur et il a il a vraiment
passé un cap cette année le fait
aujourd'hui qui est pas de combat ils
auront les choses complexes parce que
c'est dur à situer mais je pense qu'il a
ce qu'il faut et qu'il a il a un profil
de deux façons de jouer et un profit les
personnalités qui peuvent être un bon
site pour pour pour une carrière et demi
puisque souvent avec la voix nous on
pense à son physique quand on voit jouer
on voit tout de suite qu'il a énormément
de talent mais on le sent encore un peu
frêle évidemment ellison est ce que ça
c'est pas parmi les petites
interrogations comment est-ce que lui
peut sable pour s adapter à une bière
c'est un jeu c'est un joueur longiligne
je les ai vus évoluer un petit peu
physiquement je trouve qu'il a il ay là
il a gagné il a gagné des volumes sur le
haut là l'heure actuelle les joueurs qui
ne jouent pas s'ils ne sont pas dans la
salle de muscu et s'ils font pas nous
tire c'est un petit peu du temps de
perdu donc je pense que ça c'est ce qui
peut renforcer après derrière je ne sais
pas si je ne sais pas si c'est forcément
très très volumineux pour un profil
commune c'est un avantage je sais pas
non plus s'il a un un morphotype à être
à être volumineux c'est plutôt un joueur
longiligne un peu un peu quoi ouais
ouais c'est ça la rapidité d'exécution
plutôt que sur
ouais ça très délié s'est passé pas le
genre de joueur qui va les mettre là
puis met l'épaule c'est pas on n'est pas
trop sur des profils comme ça c'est ça
ça me choque pas il devra toute façon
passer par là mais comme tu as dit la 18
19 ans tu peux pas non plus ou alors si
mais c'est pas légal quoi oui après j'ai
l'impression qu'on est revenu un peu de
cette idée qu'il fallait être petit
goûter alors tony parker a prouvé
pendant toute sa carrière que ça ne
servait à rien de prendre 20 kilos de
muscles en tout cas pour les sur
l'extérieur quand l intérieur au but
devenir un peu costaud mais ça que les
joueurs extérieurs peuvent justement
voir seulement du jus d'herbe comme tony
doc canal + sur le web boire du jus
d'airelles ça va être incroyable mais
c'est vrai qu'on est un peu revenu du
délire il faut prendre du muscle il faut
que tu sois très fort très vite on
travaille différemment je pense une
évolution du jeu c'est une évolution des
bords faux type aussi et puis c'est
aussi une évolution de la dir la
maîtrise de ce que font les gens sur la
préparation physique où les expertises
se développe chez les joueurs mais aussi
chez les gens qui encadre les joueurs et
qui les accompagnent et aujourd'hui tu
rends compte de toute façon sur les
postes arrières tu as besoin de quoi tu
as besoin de diversité tas dans
l'explosivité inévitablement tu as
besoin de tenir les contacts aussi parce
qu'il faut pouvoir finir au cercle
mais est ce que est ce que est ce que
c'est la peine quand on a un canton à
profit comme outil d analyse de bon de
se transformer en bonnie lui l'heure je
pense pas non plus il ya un minimum
syndical à avoir mais je pense que
l'évolution des pratiques sur la propre
physique joue aussi sur ces choses là tu
travailles de moins en moins aujourd'hui
comme avant où tu es vraiment prendre du
volume du volume de l'hypertrophie sais
c'est pas forcément ce qu'il faut tu
crois vraiment une sélection au top 10
top stock de tidiane sy avait pas eu
tout ce bazar je dois vous parfait dans
un monde dans un monde parfait je
t'aurais dit que j'y croyais pas ce que
pense qu'une part j'ai envie pour le
gamin qui réussissent parce que c'est un
peu notre but à tous un côtier des
jeunes joueurs comme ça on a envie qu'il
arrive et puis j'ai suffisamment vu
jouer s'entraîner et puis discuté avec
pas mal d'anciens coéquipiers à lui
notamment franck à celle que je que
j'habite moi à boulazac qui joue avec
lui
deux ans bon quand quand des mecs comme
ça qu'on lui dise en professionnalisme
ne te dise balle le gamin le gamin il a
quelque chose tu as envie d'y croire ces
mecs là et qui sont sur le terrain toi
tu es dans les tribunes tu regarde jouer
ces mecs l'action sur le terrain à
l'entraînement des cui qui disent ils à
quelque chose
bon c c'est un exemple que shit souvent
avec sur le podcast mais un préparateur
physique magna jour sur une conférence
en fait
arsène wenger en quarts venait à
l'époque où tu sais l'arsenal à bayonne
toujours sortis des jeunes joueurs si on
a un bon système de formation comme un
guerrier terre il ya 6 8 ans et avec
deux mandats wenger mais comment est ce
que vous savez qu'un joueur est prêt et
wenger a répondu bah c'est très simple
quand on joue à l'entraînement si les
mecs plus expérimentés passe la balle
aux gamins l'encouragent le point sur
elle-même confiance on peut le mettre
sur le terrain on peut le mettre sur t1
la gestion de counter la gestion d'erman
kunter qui coache kia à cholet l'a
beaucoup piqué par situation là parfois
bencher parfois a lancé que cette terre
a et c sas à développer quelque chose et
cette année le la façon qui à callac au
beach avec le coach et c'était simple
une erreur deux erreurs on sort on
discute un peu on y retourne il n'y
avait pas de changement sanctions ou
autres il n'y avait pas non plus de
permissivité mais cette année le joueur
était coaché et en plus coaché par un
ancien meneur de jeu qui avait connu
quand même le très haut niveau européen
le lien en visitant quoi ouais le nord
après barman coûtera fait un très bon
travail avec un joli pas c'est juste que
je parle du cap qui est rond chic est
franchie sur le fait de passer à
l'étranger parce que tu sors de ta zone
de confort c'est un petit peu ce que les
gens avaient comme questions par rapport
à tia le fait qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient chez lui nature est à cholet
choix laissé chez lui ici tu veux et et
quelque part ben quand tu es chez toi
c'est toujours plus facile
le fait de partir en plus en aval
nouvelles cultures et c'était assez pour
moi c'est un très bon choix d'accord les
dons qui était annoncé très très bon
début de saison qui a un peu reculé
maintenant les plans et l'autre
hippiques en tout cas ce mois la plupart
des modes draft quand juste toi cette
saison théo le problème de théo mal
annoncé qu'il a été blessé deux fois
deux fois coup sur coup il a revenu
blessé de sa première expérience avec
avec l'équipe de france
la faute à pas de chance un petit peu
donc ça ça quelque part malheureusement
tu paye surtout à cet âge là où c'est
quand les choses s'enchaînent et que
battus tu prends beaucoup d'information
puis tu prends là il passe il faut la
folle à point pour la porter à gérer
face il faut la digérer
il a explosé il a explosé à la face du
monde l'an dernier où les gens se sont
dit oui il ya quelque chose se passe un
truc aussi eu ses sept petits pépins le
fait que bas cette année là la
concurrence de matthew strazeele et et
peut-être aussi grignoté quelques
minutes parce que mathieu au fait une
bonne saison et puis le fait que théo
mettre un petit peu de temps à retrouver
le rythme aussi peut-être des questions
qui sont soulevées après je pense aussi
que ça reste un joueur de vingt joueurs
de grande qualité
alors les comparaisons avec les années
nous inquiètent pas plus que ça par le
post le poste est encore ouais encore ce
qui n était plus sur une espèce de
l'espèce de combos moderne entre loin un
tweener un petit peu entre le 1 et le 2
mai qui sait faire un peu les deux
thomas lennon c'est quand même plus dur
c'est quand même plus du cerveau de
l'exécutant c1
c'est un vrai meneur de jeu 10 au 13
novembre
ouais c'est plus et ça c'est un flou
général voilà c'est ça c'est c'est un
joueur comme ça qui est qui et
disciplinée qui exécutent c'est je pense
ce sera deux trajectoires et de
carrières différentes et deux profils
différents mais à mai pour théo les
questions elles sont elles sont je pense
légitime après derrière il faut pas non
plus la place pour mes amis d'envergure
pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain
parce que on est quand même un joueur
qui était qui était très en vue l'an
dernier cette année bon il a fait il a
fait y ait eu une demi saison pour tout
le monde et malgré tout les championnats
sont arrêtés un bruit commence à être
bien aussi
donc non je pense qu'il faut pas dormir
dessus non plus il ya il a quelque chose
en plus et je pense que je pense à théo
je vous dis qu'effectivement la c1 avec
beaucoup de malheurs de jeu de bon
niveau avec son vécu par ce moment il
est en forme nous qu'on parlait
d'ailleurs d'avoir joué en europe dans
des équipes qui comptent et jean ping
france sur l'euroligue c'est des choses
qui auraient pu compter justement dans
les work out où tu joues contre le
démettre de ton âge sur ton post
et c'est là aussi où tu aurais pu te te
révéler en fait parce que je t'aurais
pas tremblé ce niveau damas nie
complètement
mais c'est la seconde c'est ce sujet et
à leur lait les contextes créé les
muschick quelque part quand quand a été
capable de jouer dans dans des salles
difficiles en euroligue côté qu'un
peuple de jouer face à face à des
façades et des cours aux joueurs
confirmés qui sont pas loin des
standards nba voir voir des joueurs voir
des joueurs des joueurs nba dans dans ce
qu'ils peuvent dans ce qu'ils peuvent
faire je pense notamment au joueur
d'efes pilsen la dont le nom m'échappe
cruellement larkin quand tu joues contre
dès qu'on aime contre des joueurs comme
ça tu es proche du standard et demi et
donc quelque part comment je mange
ouais c'est ça c est clairement de bâle
ville de demain tu t'habilles work out à
faire comme des joueurs qui sortent de
fac
certes ce sera des bons joueurs mais ils
n'ont pas joué ils n'ont pas joué ces
mecs là toute l'année ils ont pas droit
kaona s'ils n'ont pas joué au fener ils
ont pas jouer contre le barça
alors oui bon ça peut être duke sakho
est jouée une si ça peut être ce que tu
veux mais malgré tout voilà il ya eu
quelques tirages des relais car il ya un
vrai qu'après nature voilà évidemment
d'avant soit parmi les questions qu'on
se poser c'est est ce que on est capable
de renvoyer cinq joueurs français ou
plus l'année prochaine en une pierre à
l'arrivée on pense à aquitaine si on
pense aussi à il fonce on pense à qui
d'autre on pense à ailly est-ce qu'il y
en a donné un mois à voir au hall du
genre aujourd'hui pour moi voyage il
s'appelle de cheval ndèye de cholet oui
absolument oui
non je rejoins aujourd'hui je pense que
je suis allé deux indiscutables tu as tu
vois comment tu vas pas quillanais tri
yann et théo qui pour moi voilà son sont
indiscutables après derrière on parle
pas qu'elle meure de poker menteur tout
à l'heure je pense que pour un ippon son
peut rentrer là dedans après pour pour
ndèye on peut rentrer un petit peu là
dedans aussi pour quillan ce lycée
pareil c'est des profils un petit peu un
petit peu différent dans le cas de
dispenses tu vas être sur un sur un
profil de joueur tu peux en faire un
vrai spécialiste défensif sur plusieurs
postes en nba ya quelques jours ce
serait comme meilleur défenseur nba est
un peu de stars lui donc ce sont des
profils qui ont des vraies cartes à
jouer en nba vu refuser les gars c'est
hillary et puis il ya une chose il ya
une chose qu'on enfin construit ni assez
peu et qui fonce mexès un mec
actuellement qui est brillant et éduquer
au dessus de la moyenne
non pas que les autres foyers hausse et
parce que j'ai dû tout mais dans la
capacité qui aura à s'adapter et
compagnie c'est c'est une espèce de sas
est un touche à tout qui est plein de
choses la photo de la musique je suis
plein de trucs différents
je pense que c'est cette cdc pour moi
c'est lé signe d'intelligence hors
basket qui font que le mec sera
s'adapter s'il un shot il sera prend le
truc donc donc il a construit quelque
chose là dessus qu'il y accueillait le
chili à moi à titre perso j'ai envie de
voir réussir parce que la gale est un
mec c'est un mec intéressant qui a
jamais rien lâché là où certains
auraient pu dire bon et on a quelques
conneries je rentre à la maison
sa mise là dans cette famille et puis là
il a un talent il ya quelque chose donc
donc ouais vraiment vraiment envie de
voir arriver puis dans le cas de dans le
cadre dans le cas de ndèye de cholet
pareil je suis un pro dans un registre
défensif ça peut ça peut ça peut ça peut
glisser sur le deuxième tour et
peut-être une équipe qui peut
s'intéresser à lui
je pense je pense que le ram on est on
est sur deux on a en a deux tiers
différent on a vraiment kilian et théo
qui peuvent qui peuvent espérer quelque
chose de de cohérent sur le premier tour
et puis après les nos trois autres se
glissait sur un sur un strapontin
et puis peut-être réussir à faire un
très bon coup justement par le biais du
contexte par le biais de leurs capacités
aussi il ya peut-être quelque chose à
faire il ya un truc qu'on a peu dit
aujourd'hui mais qui est très important
persuadé que tu es avec moi c'est aussi
saisir sur 90 unités de cette manière
quand tu es dans un entre deux et ça
marche évidemment pour tous les
contextes de la vie mais la nba te
permets d'avoir par moments des petites
ouvertures sur un workout sur un 5 5 sur
un mât j'en sais rien où il ya plein de
exemple différents il pense tout à fait
le type de deux profils de basketteurs
ou sur un entraînement il peut
impressionner scout il peut
impressionner lundi m ils disent se
mettait dans deux ans ce sera mon
stoppeur titulaire ou dans trois ans
donc c'est aussi un important à prendre
en compte quand tu es joueur jeunes
joueurs c'est que tu as une chance il
faut la saisir
tu connais l'histoire de norrath de 10
nobili un bâtiment tu sais qu'elle s'est
joué sur un pile ou face
un scout un scout 15 scouts européens
qui est décédé aujourd'hui que sa
période moeurs qui nous a raconté quand
je passais mon diplôme chiba à l'époque
j'ai bossé pour les spurs donc les ans
près c'est ce qui nous a racontée est ce
que ce que c'est vrai ce que c'est
romancé je sais pas mais il nous
explique en fait il était donc avec l
éclaircie buford avec popovych et de
trois autres personnes sur le à bosser
sur le dossier ils ont deux profils
équivalent de deux joueurs étrangers
donc d'un côté d'un côté de ginobili
l'autre neuilly n'a jamais voulu une
guerre le nom un obstacle plus important
avec ginobili mais dit ne liez pas
forcément prêt tout de suite tout de
suite de l'autre côté un risque un peu
moins élevé mais un plafond un peu moins
élevé également y retournent le truc qui
retourne le truc qui attend le truc qui
tourne le truc à 2 heures du matin
capable de prendre la décision et si on
faisait la pièce je sais pas s'il y est
je sais pas si l'histoire je sais je dis
non pas seulement parce que les deux
mais il nous l'a dit l'autre joueur
avait une belle carrière aussi et que
c'est un très bon joueur mais si tu veux
c'est il a sûrement peut-être un peu
romancée les choses mais la part de
chance elle est la part de chance et de
contexte elle et elle est énorme alors
tu sais comme moi qui ai les joueurs qu
aurait pu faire carrière s'il est tombé
ailleurs comme inversement s'il n'était
pas tombé là où ils sont tombés ce sera
peut-être jamais passé saleuses ont peu
de voix qu on pourrait citer en tout cas
dans dont le côté positif
tu vois dernièrement honnêtement moi cet
album green je vois qu'ils bien qualités
intrinsèques de haut niveau c'est un
vrai joueur nba aucun problème oui mais
jamais il devient ce qu'il est ce qu'il
est devenu
si david il se blesse pas si l'epa
warriors 6 voilà est donc évidemment
l'environnement et puisque tu es vous
l'avoir soin de ta et chercher les
choses mais très bonnes copies le film
fit au final est parfait parce que ben
tous tous ces lignes est correctement
surtout celle du correctement pour lui
sur sur la situation dans laquelle il
est aujourd'hui monté comme t'apprêtes à
l'aimer consignes en europe parce qu'ils
n'ont jamais trouvé de schott et puis or
on parlait de larkin tout à l'heure ce
qu'est cette clause 3 0
ouais les regarde chaude civile est
similaire
si la fée coin de franchise avant
d'arriver à détroit donc des histoires
des exemples comme ça dans l'histoire il
y en a un paquet mais après voilà c'est
pour ça on
en outre le podcast c'est la question du
shit elle est super importante et une
situation tu réponds comme tu l'entends
mais quelqu'un qui va bosser pour la sig
alors qu'on parle d'environnement et une
joueurs français je pense toujours
évidemment à franquin évidemment tu as
quand on parle d'environnement
je pense qu'il est tombé dans le pire
environnement possible presque pur
produit par son style de jeu c'est ouais
alors que alors que ouais c mais c'est
dur à dire avant parce que aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on dit à new york qui voudra
acheter
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que tu fais tu fais
en sorte de peur que gilbert moi j'ai
les armes et c'est ça c'est ça notre le
truc il a donc est ce qu est ce qu est
ce qu est ce que est ce que est ce que
c'est le problème du joueur à ce que
c'est une croix de la franchise est ce
que c'est le fait qu'avec une qu'avec le
coach au départ ça serait pas fonctionné
avec fidel se perfectionner moi je te
cache pas que quand j'ai vu des rumeurs
de trade sa dette il ya deux ans quand
on a commencé à parler d éventuellement
à brooklyn juste passer nul n'a la
cellule brooklyn
j'imaginais le vix avec atkins le
sinistre est-ce que c'est pas quelque
chose qui peut se passer correctement
comme avec avec avec une carrière ça
pouvait très bien se passer à dallas
également c'est voilà je pense que là
c'est plus c'est un peu l'espèce de de
marasme ambiant qui a tiré là
aujourd'hui
bon c c'est ça s'en va dans la même
direction mais tant que dolan sera
derrière à prendre des décisions sera de
pure mais c'est vrai que dans le cas de
franck ni qui lasse et c'est frustrant
parce ya quelque chose il ya une île
talent quelque chose mais je connais par
les calibrages avoir mis quoi j'ai dit
ouais j'espère que l'histoire est pas
fier parce que c'est un mec intelligent
il ya pas de raison et c'est un super
joueur de basket parce que souvent tu
sais quand on parle de francon
on met en avant son état d'esprit le
fait soit un mec intelligent c'est
surtout un super joueur de basket
forcément ça j'aurais 9e et c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup à offrir gens
ne te dire on l'a vu la dernière équipe
de france le match ou des etats unis
c'est un must eat voici serait dû être
le match fondateur
donc tu vois j'ai eu la chance de le
croiser quelques années gt gt moi je
m'occupais de la vidéo l'équipe de
france u20 et il a fait un bout de
rapport avec nous mais il avait un abus
heures qui était pas en très bon état
donc on n'a pas pu l'emmener jusqu'au
jusqu'au ses e mails et quelques bouts
de matches qu'il a joués avec nous on a
joué on jouait vraiment un ton au dessus
parce que c'est un mec intéressant et
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire un travail
de deux heures en train avec des changes
est un peu s'il va lui trouver que c'est
vraiment un mec intéressant c'est un mec
du basket c'est vraiment vraiment un mec
intelligent et non pas encore j'ai pas
dire qu'ils ont toujours sur bet on sait
pas le propos ouais il n'y a là aussi
c'est un jour avec la tête sur les
épaules et puis qui voit là c'est pas je
pense que les choses se sont emboîtées
correctement parce que parce que je suis
sur le basket sur le basket voilà comme
tu dis il a eu son match référence en
équipe de france s'il ya par exemple
soit pas quelque chose qui seront
première absolument job et les
commentaires les gars n'hésitez pas
poser des questions on va se prendre dix
quinze minutes là pour répondre à vos
questions
si vous en avez on a évidemment parlé
d'attitude au début donc on va re posté
cette vidéo pourrait re re voir parce
que refaire le débat mais c'était très
intéressant romain il serait dommage de
tout répéter nous une fois nous
n'hésitez pas à poser vos petites
questions si vous en avez indiqué en
tout cas là tu parles de francs knysna
qui dit il a tout du basketteur parfait
mais trop généreux ces concerts dans un
sport collectif c'est surtout quand
elles viennent qui est un sport
collectif
nous on dit tout le temps le sport le
plus individuel de tout espoir qu à la
nba évidemment c'est le paroxysme de
cette idée là en europe on sait que ce
sera différent pour lui mais il odyx on
va pas lui en vouloir pour ça l'entente
possible absolument
une vingtaine d'années qui
multiplieraient ce que tu pense qu'on
peut faire mieux que 5 français drafté
c'est compliqué un peu aujourd'hui je
sais mais qu'est-ce que tu en dis toi sa
part à delhi qu'un déjà déjà 5 ce sera
un beau score mais plus de 5 ça paraît
délicat jeu je vois pas qui demain de
sortir nu peut sortir du chapeau tu
parlais tout à l'heure de jardin et qui
a fait une
quelques donc a commencé à montrer à
montrer les choses cette année
je ne sais pas si c'est pas je sais pas
les sépales juste pour tester la
température pour voir ça me parait sa
part un petit auto même si le joueur a
des qualités des qualités indéniables
après leur jeu là comme ça tu as de but
en blanc je vois pas qui peut ce qui
peut se mêler aux eaux à la discussion
qui a entonné manche aprilia a pris un
peu de retard par rapport à ses
collègues
même si elle a du talent il encore dit
encore du boulot c'est trop tôt pour lui
je vois pas derrière qui peut qui peut
vraiment aller aller chercher ainsi elle
soit déjà bon c'est ouais on se rend pas
compte
c'est déjà dans d'avoir un ou deux
régulière c'est déjà bien après
conscient mais 4,6 en mai 5 tant mieux
mais il faut envoyer des jours un billet
c'est un process quand même est faux
voilà il faut produire absolument ya
beaucoup de sueur les commentaires qui
parlent de l'île des soeurs vivait sa
l'ancien joueur de votre forêt ce qu'ils
valent un procès d'intention qui
forcément bien mais c'est un mec sur
lequel on compte pour pourquoi pas
porter le flambeau transfère une vieille
aussi quoi il ya ilahi là il a des
arguments à faire valoir je pense
qu'elle fait son choix d'aller à
kentucky
on va boire parce que bon ça y est comme
quelques joueurs qui sont sortis là bas
on ne connait logement même pas le
travail de calipari je suis pas
forcément le plus grand fan du du coach
en question mais des récits bien des
gens mais des joueurs habillés tous les
ans donc lui lui son boulot c'est quoi
c'est de mettre des joueurs nba pour en
attirer d'autres ports que finalement
l'argent qui rentre à la fin donc par le
biais des biais d'une première idée qui
s'est arrêté les contrats de sponsoring
tout ça donc dans le mec qui fait son
boulot donc non on a tué là dessus
olivier sa rebond dans quelques-uns des
meilleurs le petit frère aussi qui est
très intéressant vous pouvez commencer à
cocher le nom puis on en reparle dans
quelques temps est ce que c'est encore
un peu tôt j'aime pas parler des joueurs
trop tôt mais il y ait dans la mine
alors il et je dois je sais plus quel et
ils doivent 14 et 15 ans la danse et
zola donc il a ça ça arrive ça arrive
derrière tranquillement mais c'est là la
sur l'année prochaine ou le vivier sa
repop peut-être entrer dans les noms des
gens sur qui sur qui discutait
effectivement moins bien donc je ne suis
pas sûr d'avoir déjà vue en france est
passé par têtu qui l'a comme ça je le
fais sinon moi mal commentaires si vous
avez une idée mais en france a critiqué
c'est quelque chose quand même
c'est la preuve que qu'on continue à
très bien s'exporter aussi dans le
basket international
j'avais un commentaire si vous avez des
questions c'est le moment si vous avez
des questions à romain sur la grave sans
pouvoir parler de pas mal de joueurs
depuis depuis le début de ce petit live
enfin avant même que je puisse dire vos
questions je te remercie romain en tout
cas parce que c'était très cool mais pas
3g
j'ai appris que j'étais sûr j'ai appris
plein de trucs mais surtout j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir d'observer tout
petit même si on s'aperçoit minutes si
vous avez des bonnes questions là y'a
pas de plaisir partagé dire que n'aura
le temps de reparler que ce soit avec
toi avec avec un excellent tous les gars
d'envergure pour préparer la draft pour
que ça se prépare une draft on va faire
des des vidéos sur chaque joueur mais
c'est de prendre une dizaine de
prospects les plus intéressants
évidemment qu'on va parler de la mélo
bol de voir des joueurs les plus
inquiets renom de cette draft mais c'est
important aussi parler des autres on va
découvrir dès l'année prochaine en nba
alors je regarde un mot sur victor ou el
bayadh nyama c'est bien dit wen madiama
très bien un petit mot sur lui qui est
la sensation
ouais donc j'ai dit tout à l'heure tu
n'aimes pas forcément parler des gens
trop trop jeunes parce qu'il ya encore
de la route à faire
il commence à beaucoup de hype autour de
lui parce que c'est un c'est un
phénomène physique d'abord parce que ça
fait il doit être de 15 de 16 quelque
chose comme ça c'est encore monter très
fin mais avec une motricité par contre
rares points lors de cette taille
je pense que le mot il ya un petit peu
d'exotisme dans la famille donc je pense
savoir d'où ça vient au niveau au niveau
de la capacité à courir mais où il ya
lui pour le coup je pense qu'on va on va
dit en parler il me semble que nanterre
va l'intégrer roster pro l'an prochain
c'était encore un petit peu tôt pour le
faire jouer régulièrement avec les
grands mais en tout cas bon ça veulent
permettre de s'entraîner dans ce
contexte là une équipe espoirs de
nanterre pour les gens pour l'occasion
des world où il y aura également le lot
de joueurs à 2,16 la maxime renault qui
va arriver là au milieu donc espèce de
star wars bio twin towers là qui peut
être intéressant donc la victoire à
banias main un vrai vrai projet un vrai
problème pour lui c'est qu'évidemment
parle de ses mensurations même de ses
stats
valve il ya un truc qui impressionne
tout le monde quand on voit jouer c'est
sa facilité dans le jeu il aime faire
des traces des petits on n'a pas trouvé
comparaison et pour le coup on retrouve
un peu de boris diaw c'est à dire dans
la finesse dans le jeu ea tentative de
spectacles de ce père qui fait mais pas
solo d'inclure ses coéquipiers non il ya
un vrai il ya un vrai que lui basket il
ay ay ay ay l'altruisme danse qui fait
il n'a pas peur de poser la balle au sol
il n'a pas peur de tenter les choses y a
il ya une espèce de talent inné je
vendais l'éternelle question entre entre
eux entre l'inné et l'acquis lui lui sur
la partie n'est c'est assez énorme et
c'est pour ça que je vous aime et c'est
du temps aux gens j'ai envie d'y croire
aux aveux je pense que bon on va rendre
plus ça va et plus aux enfers sur lui
mais bon c'est encore un très très
jeunes joueurs mais tu sais où vivent
les abl
oui mais c'est puis c'est le jeu c'est
normal c'est ce qu'il faut il faut être
premier en parler il faut être
il faut être premier à trouver le petit
truc et que c'était rectorat c'est
normal mais ça c'est ça me pose aucun
souci c'est juste que la presse la ccl
l'entraîneur qui parle de casquettes
je pense que je pense qu'il faut il faut
laisser un petit peu de temps parfois
aussi parlé trop trop tôt c'est encore
une fois la hype
là elle a fait des carrières maintenant
détruit aussi donc déjà deux jours à
suivre
est ce que tu penses toi j'ai un peu
plus loin mais est ce que toi tu penses
en tant que coach est aussi intervenant
dans les vestiaires puisque tu es parti
d'envergure que c'est normal que les
médias en général vraiment globalement
je considérais sociaux même de temps
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça crée des eip je
trouve ça normal que d'un côté les
médias en général crée des as mais ce ne
serait pas vraiment au coach et à
l'environnement
très proche du joueur de protéger en
fait les joueurs et de les laisser
éclore facilement le problème c'est que
monaco tête à tête elles étaient les
gens qui vont vouloir comme chauny
sortir le le petit truc la piste d'un
faux tout de suite dire c'est moi qui
les lui que cet art etc puis l'autre
problème c'était aussi des coachs et là
je je je sais bien propos général se met
dix personnes en dix ans a en
particulier chez les coaches qui servent
de ça pour ce marque était même bien sûr
voilà bien sûr
un train après après aujourd'hui on
attend les entraîneurs en france qui
font leur boulot qui développe les gens
d y ait des gens qui forment qui font
travailler c'est très bien mais moi
comme je dis toujours faut pas oublier
que le joueur c'est le coeur du projet
le joueur doit être le coeur du projet
si si on est là pour accompagner
quelqu'un mais qu'on ne laisse pas le
joueur être au centre de l'attention
c'est très compliqué parce qu'on faut
sur une fausse ce travail je le basket
il appartient aux joueurs
qu'est ce qu'on veut sur le losc est il
a passé vingt joueurs et les jeunes
joueurs je pense qu'il faut leur donner
du temps mais moi j'ai énormément de mal
avec ce concept de dire on a développé
telle ou telle personne j'ai développé
d'autres personnes non c'est pas une
légende wayne pas on accompagne les
sportifs nous entraîneurs on
accompagnait sportifs ont accompagné
cette recette que qui qu'un joueur se
soit développée dans un contexte de club
particulier oui je veux bien l'entendre
par contre tu entends dire on a formé un
tel on a développé un tel ça c'est
quelque chose que dont je sais pas mais
je cours il est notre question là qui
est super intéressante et parce que ça
m'intéresse d'avoir ton avis là dessus
la delta qui dit vous pensez quoi de
l'influencé des réseaux sociaux sur les
carrières des jeunes prospects
je pense pas que je suis les jeunes
prospects mais bon c'est quelque chose
on en parle souvent avec mon camarade
mon camarade yasin awadi qui est à
l'image qui est qui et 8 sur le player
développement de talent ni moche qui a
notamment travaillé que six coups 4 avec
rudy gobert avec accès de bouteilles
également donc un mec a quand même déjà
fait des choses à titre perso où tu vois
nous ce qui nous insupporte c'est ce
qu'on appelle les maîtres nageurs c'est
tout ce qu'on voit comme travers nuel
d'été et les mecs qui se tapent dessus
des fritons mousse des trucs comme ça
cirque un bon lot de faux contextualiser
ce qu'on fait donc ça se trouve c'est un
des grands mots des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui comme le fait de courir des
roues tracteur enfin les choses
totalement totalement hors de propos ou
au delà de ça au delà de ça je pense que
c'est quelqu'un qui était dans le
coaching dans le coaching de 2,2 de
manager et d'entraîneurs qui s'appelle
nicolas rabot qu'on parlait c'est aussi
ce qu'on appelle le faire savoir
niveau du faire savoir il faut être
conscient que toi moi on est tous une
marque à proprement parler situe en
avant n'est plus perçue à faire valoir
et c'est quelque chose que les joueurs
on devrait très tôt leur apprendre à
maîtriser ces choses là pour pas
s'exposer et pour pas se retrouver aussi
aussi un peu vite
le truc parce que aujourd'hui tu vas
chercher des informations sur victor
wanyama par exemple sur la radio ce
foutu plein de gens parlent mais ça peut
aussi une pression il faut savoir se
protéger de ces trucs là et je pense que
ben ali qui s'apprête aujourd'hui suivi
limal tout lampes collectées sur l'avers
taylor donc c'est pour dire c'est plus
ma génération mais les réseaux sociaux
jouent un rôle il faut savoir les
utiliser donc dans le faire savoir
correctement il faut savoir ce que tu
donnes comme un faux parce
qu'aujourd'hui les scouts nba sont pas
fous comme tout le monde ils ont des
burner est fière de l'est compte
instagram des uns des autres et que
c'était et c'est donc bon ben si tu as
17 18 ans pile tu poses des photos de
soirées sur un lendemain de match où tu
as perdu
fectivement ça peut pondre soit là ça
peut m'aider tiré de flag comme ça sur
ton parcours
donc il faut les réseaux sociaux il faut
savoir utiliser faut aussi savoir son
protégé si une réponse de vieux qui se
fait mais c'est non mais c'est vrai
c'est que quand elles se présentent chez
moi j'ai eu le cas plein de fois ça
c'est ça fait neuf ans que sur les
équipes de france jeunes féminines on a
eu plein de cas ces dernières années où
à peine arrivé sur le site de
compétition on a des scouts de qui
bossent pour des facs directement ou des
agents qui bossent pour les facs aussi
des équipes universités en chef qui
contactent les filles en direct par
exemple sur les réseaux sociaux
donc c'est des trucs sur lesquels nous
n'expliquent toujours joueur ce que tu
poses protéger de ces trucs là parce que
parce que c'est juste pas possible que
les réseaux sociaux celui qui sait les
utilisent aujourd'hui sera en faire
quelque chose d'intéressant c'est un peu
plate forme au contraire pour pour
gagner en crédibilité
mais je suis pas sûr que des joueurs à
17 18 ans il est forcément cette cette
logique là en tête ou alors c'est des
gens déjà d'exception dans leur approche
fakih a posé cette super question qui
polluent avec des cours de gestion des
réseaux sociaux
une bonne idée ça existe je certains
seront peut-être de la sensibilisation
nous je sais qu'en équipe de france on
en parle on en parle systématiquement
aux filles parce que il faut il faut le
faire ça nous paraît important je sais
que sur les derniers championnats
d'europe que j'ai fait il ya deux ans
c'était les u16 les u16 féminine la
chine valait 1 une demi journée ont fait
il ya toujours deux journées entre
guillemets off pendant la compet
je suis ruinée sur une des journées off
la cib après une demi-journée pour
justement avoir une sensibilisation au
niveau des joueuses de différentes
nations pourraient mieux qu'un petit peu
sur ces choses là parce que ça me paraît
sain parachute important d'accord très
bien mais tu as raison
alors c'est peut-être un tout petit peu
plus jeune que toi et moi c'est ça je
suis passé de l'autre côté la part de la
trentaine donc parfois aussi je les
réponses de vieux cons de vieux cons
mais en réalité ce que nos jeunes avec
les plus jeunes ceux qui ont 15 20 ans
aujourd'hui ont grandi totalement
différemment en fait de nous des fautes
c'était en cinquième je sais pas pour
toi mais en tout cas aujourd'hui c'est
presque considérer comme tard et mon
téléphone je pouvais soit appelée choix
soient joués ce n'est qu' on était loin
de thébaux d'instagram donc il faut
prévenir les plus jeunes qu'eux il ya
des dérives ça peut être dangereux
faites gaffe protégez vous ne mettez pas
toute votre vie soit réseaux sociaux
puisque derrière c'est vous qui allez
payer quand un truc et sur internet il
reste sur internet c'est ça plutôt à toi
tu vas lui à toi tu le sais d'autant
plus parce que c'est votre métier aussi
si votre coeur d'activité mais que c'est
encore une fois c est rugueux de vieux
con mais je préfère le dire et c'est
bien ce qu'a fait peur face cette
sensibilisation
c'est le trait le rôle d'une fédération
de toute manière mais ce qu'on devrait
creuser les clubs la ligue
la fédé en compte devrait creuser
justement je dis pas que c'est pas le
cas je lui ai aucune idée
mais creuse en tout cas l'idée qu' il
faut parler de ça le plus souvent
possible ou plus jeunes et leur faire
prendre confiance conscience que ça peut
être à titre perso les entraîneurs que
je connexion sur les pôles espoirs de la
fédération ce soit des soies des cadres
techniques de d'état soit sur les
entraîneurs sly des ligues régionales
la plupart des de ce que je connais ont
déjà des approches sur ces choses là
j'imagine qu'au centre fédéral sur des
sottises jouer après j'ai pensé je sais
pas la fédération en tout cas à des
cahiers des charges précis sur ces
choses là nous entraîneurs sur les sur
les équipes nationales ons dans la
directive aussi sur ces trucs là et
c'est important de le faire et je pense
c'est sûrement fait mais aujourd'hui je
vais pas dire que c'est j'ai pas la
certitude je préfère
oui bien sûr bien sûr merci beaucoup en
tout cas aux mains avec théière en forme
la discuter de jeunes prospects de draft
nba g-league aussi on vous invite à
regarder la vidéo en dur je verrai si je
vais mettre sur instagram je l'enverrai
aussi à l'écran que vous puissiez la
diffuser c'est très intéressant en tout
cas d'avoir ton point de vue le coach
sur pas mal d'échecs jeunes joueurs et
puis on aura l'occasion de reparler de
tout ça avec grand plaisir sur instagram
pourquoi pas mais pourquoi pas aussi
sans problème j'arrive à me connecter
maintenant qui a pas de fichier
une fois que tu as fait une fois presque
voir boxer ça c'est comme le vélo ça
mettra comme absolument
merci beaucoup roman je te quitte là et
j'ai programme c'est le programme de la
semaine sur son parti c'est un vrai
plaisir
merci beaucoup merci à tous portez vous
bien les amis encore une fois merci à
romain qui a assuré qui va être
assistant coach de la sig à la cidéral
prochaine donc à strasbourg donc on
pourra en reparler de tous un peu plus
tard je me suis gardé encore 5 minutes
puisque demain c'est là la grande
reprise des des vidéos surfer steam sur
youtube et demain on a une vidéo qu'on
attend pas trop d encombres demain matin
avec nicolas batum sur le sujet que
vaudra ce titre nba il ya plein de
choses plein d'infos qu'on va essayer de
vous donner sur la bulle sur le format
de ces play-offs qui aura plein plein de
choses
ça commencera donc le 20 juillet puis ça
se terminera au plus tard le 2 octobre
derrière à la draft nasri a une si
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et de deux
trucs qu'on aime c'est à dire le basket
il a une bien puisque c'est quand même
l'information principale yanis ça sort
dès demain je vois un invité surprise un
invité surprise qui déboule mais qui
est-ce qui s en vient à parler
qui a envie de raconter sa fille qui s
il se baissaient pas là bas on est là